[Music]
blue had a baby that's impossible
hey girl
you look just like your mother
[Music]
i promise you i am gonna get her back
genetic power has now been unleashed
we made a terrible mistake
the doomsday clock might be about out of
time
if our world's gonna survive what
matters is what we do now
i could use your expertise
you comment or what
a baby raptor i made a promise we would
bring her home
you made a promise to a dinosaur yeah
what
[Music]
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right
see not so bad
[Music]
i wanted to show them something that
wasn't an illusion
something that was real
something that we could
see and touch
creation
is an act of sheer will
life
will find a way
we can't keep her here forever
they find her we're never gonna see her
again we gotta protect her that's our
job
humans and dinosaurs can't coexist
[Music]
we created an ecological disaster
ally settler
alan grant
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you
you coming or what
[Music]
we're racing toward the extinction of
our species
we not only lack dominion over nature
[Music]
we're subordinate to it
[Music]
[Music]
come back i always come back
that's another plane right not exactly
don't move
figure why do they always have to go
bigger
[Music]
[Music]
you